x-men New Mutants was about to become a
real hit
at first glance that had quite a bit
ride with the low budget and the three
young film stars Maisie Williams Enya
Taylor joy and Charlie Heaton however
many fans have been wondering for quite
some time when x-men new mutants will be
released and the fact that the announce
tree recordings which are supposed to
make the movie darker still haven't
taken place even led to incomprehension
among the actress and yet Taylor joy was
less interviewed in the end of February
and could only give the disappointing
answer that the film would find its way
to the screen at some point her co-star
Maisie Williams became more direct and
said who knows when the hell it's going
to come out but why has the film been on
ice for such a long time director Josh
Boone who has been a fan of the New
Mutants since childhood according to his
own statement wrote a script together
with Nate Lee in 2015 and it didn't seem
to be that bad at all after all even
comic creator Bill syncovich was
impressed by the script it is also clear
that it is certainly not a bad idea to
present members of the x-men in
individual films which can best be seen
in the example of Deadpool the crux of
the matter is that x-men producer Simon
Kinberg himself was busy shooting Dark
Phoenix and therefore was not able to be
at the new mutant set as a result the
communication between director Boone and
the studio was more than bumpy the
script was completely gathered and
turned into a fantasy story instead of a
superhero horror movie after the
shootings were finished at the end of
2017 and the test screenings were
positive they decided to make a rather
creepy movie due to the itch horror hype
the post-production also hasn't been
announced yet and won't take place in
the nearest future the official release
date on 22nd of August this year is more
like a parody since it's not even
certain if the movie will come at all we
have fresh footage of Marvel's
spider-man far from home has already
known spider-man leaves New York City
behind for a city tour the new posters
shows snapshots of spider-man in Berlin
in front of the Brandenburg Gate in
Venice in front of the ponte rialto and
in london on top of the London Eye and
just three months after Avengers end
games by the man far from home we'll
continue with the next chapter of the
Marvel superhero saga spider-man has not
only on a European tour to see the
beautiful cities but has his hands full
dealing with the elementary creatures
earth fire and water
how exactly spider-man far from home
will turn out can be seen in the cinemas
on 5th of July 2009 T on Monday evening
Apple introduced its new streaming
service Apple TV plus the new rebel
product to Amazon Prime Netflix & Co
will be launched in autumn why Apple now
also wants to open up the market for
streaming providers is obvious after all
the sales figures for iPhones have been
failing for quite some time and as a
global company you have to open up new
markets in order to remain relevant this
will also include an own credit card and
a payment platform for video games if
you believe the New York Times there are
currently about two dozen in-house
productions in the making which will go
online and fall the competition is
definitely tough as amazon prime and
netflix together currently dominate most
of the market nevertheless it will be
interesting to see how Apple will
present itself with Apple TV Plus in the
fall after all according to current
information there will be a series by
Steven Spielberg and live talk shows by
Oprah Winfrey Hollywood star Angelina
Jolie could become a marble heroine in
the near future in the Eternals the
story is about godlike beings which are
in an intergalactic war according to
Marvel boss Kevin Feige the complete
plot of the film could cover tens of
thousands of years which role Jolie will
play exactly isn't known yet but the
commitment to the Eternals would be her
superhero debut the shooting is
scheduled for this summer and the
release date is even planned for the end
of 2020
after a successful Halloween reboot
horror producer Jason Blum will now take
on the next horror classic Andrew
Fleming's the Kraft
loom simply keeps an eye on how to
reboot decades-old horror movies for
little money to make groundbreaking
bucks of his profits take Halloween for
example which had production cost of
just 10 million u.s. dollars and brought
in two hundred and fifty three million
u.s. dollars worldwide and like this it
is supposed to happen with the craft and
best case originally planned was a
sequel to the 1969 original film in
which a new group of women practice Isis
dark magic it is unclear at the Blum who
has recently secured the rights of the
movie
also go along the path of the secret or
rather the path of the reboot in
Halloween it was also a sequel which
worked really well so what is the craft
all about in a nutshell it's about a
group of four young girls who realize
that they can use dark magic to
influence things in their favor however
as it is so often the case playing
around with dark magic isn't without
consequences at all it's not yet known
when the craft will be released yet we
can hope that blue mouse will soon
realize the project
[Music]